[Música]
Rusia lanzó un ataque masivo sobre
Ucrania según las autoridades de kiev
Moscú disparó 67 misiles pero las
fuerzas ucranianas derribaron 51 además
fue celebró la medida del parlamento
europeo que declaró a Rusia estado
promotor del terrorismo
en Jerusalén dos bombas detonaron en dos
paradas de autobús una de las
explosiones mató un joven de 16 años
ninguna organización ha reivindicado el
ataque pero jamás y la hija islámica lo
han celebrado además en una redada
israelí en cisjordania un joven
palestino murió tras recibir un disparo
desde 2014 50.000 personas murieron
mientras intentaban migrar según la
organización internacional de las
migraciones la mortalidad en las
fronteras se explica por la
fortificación del Norte global que
impide las rutas migratorias seguras
para las personas del Sur
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
este miércoles Rusia lanzó un ataque
masivo sobre el territorio ucraniano
según las autoridades de kiev Moscú
disparó 67 misiles pero las fuerzas
ucranianas derribaron 51 Rusia dirigió
30 de estos misiles sobre kiev donde
mataron a cinco personas el ataque
múltiple también impactó sobre un
hospital maternal en sa purilla sin
embargo el principal objetivo de la
ofensiva continúa siendo la
infraestructura energética y
precisamente hoy el parlamento europeo
declaró a Rusia como estado promotor del
terrorismo una medida simbólica
solicitada de forma reiterada por el
presidente ucraniano así recibió el
anuncio vuelo de merceleski
el parlamento de la Unión Europea ha
declarado hoy a Rusia como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo Rusia
demostró a todo el mundo que es verdad
lanzándose 67 cohetes contra nuestras
infraestructuras contra nuestra energía
contra civiles el resultado es trágico
hay un gran número de heridos Hay
muertos por favor acepten mis
condolencias a todos los que han perdido
a sus familiares y allegados en cuanto
al suministro de Electricidad y agua
todos están trabajando reconstruiremos
todo lo superaremos todo porque somos un
pueblo inquebrantable Gracias a todos
Cuídense Gloria a Ucrania
precisamente Poco después de que el
parlamento europeo declarara a Rusia
como estado promotor del terrorismo un
grupo de hackers ha lanzado un ciber
ataque contra el legislativo europeo el
ataque ha afectado sobre todo a la
página web del parlamento de estrasburgo
así lo ha comunicado la presidenta de
esta institución de la Unión Europea
Roberta metzola
el parlamento europeo estaba bajo un
sofisticado ciber ataque Un grupo
procreming se ha atribuido la
responsabilidad nuestros expertos en
tecnología están resistiendo y
protegiendo nuestro sistemas esto luego
de que proclamamos a Rusia como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo
y en Reino Unido el tribunal supremo
dictaminó que el gobierno de Escocia no
puede convocar un nuevo referendo de
autodeterminación sin la aprobación de
Londres recordemos que en la votación de
2014 el rechazo a la independencia ganó
con un 55% de los votos sin embargo el
gobierno nacionalista escocés considera
que el brexit ha revertido la situación
Andrés granadillo nos amplía
un golpe legal a las esperanzas del
partido Nacional escocés de celebrar
otro referéndum la Independencia el
próximo octubre el tribunal supremo del
Reino Unido adictaminado por unanimidad
que la Facultad de convocar un
referéndum está reservada al parlamento
británico la primera ministra escocesa a
Nicola storgen dijo que respetaba la
sentencia del tribunal pero considera
que roja duda sobre la democracia dentro
del referéndum de la devolución de
Escocia en el que hay una especie de
descentralización del poder de Londres
sobre edimburgo en cuanto a gasto social
o recaudación de impuestos
tal vez lo que la sentencia de hoy
confirma más que nada Es que la única
garantía de igualdad para Escocia dentro
de la familia británica de Naciones es
la independencia debemos encontrar y
encontraremos otro medio democrático
legal y constitucional para que el
pueblo escocés exprese su voluntad
dijo que convertiría las próximas
elecciones generales en una votación de
impacto sobre la separación del resto de
Reino Unido haciendo campaña únicamente
sobre esa premisa Mientras tanto el
Primer Ministro de Richard sunak dio la
bienvenida al fallo creo que el pueblo
de Escocia quiere que trabajemos para
solucionar los principales retos a los
que nos enfrentamos colectivamente ya
sea la economía el apoyo al sistema de
salud o el apoyo a Ucrania ahora es el
momento de que los políticos trabajen
juntos
ha rechazado repetidamente que Escocia
celebre otro referéndum dice que el de
2014 en el que el 55% de los escoceses
rechazó la independencia sanjó la
cuestión durante una generación pero el
Partido Nacional escocés Dice que ahora
hay un mandato indiscutible debido a una
mayoría que apoya la independencia en el
parlamento Escocia se vio obligada a
abandonar la Unión Europea junto al
resto de Reino Unido Pese a que la
mayoría de los escoceses votaron en
contra del brexit
y dos bombas detonaron en dos paradas de
autobús de Jerusalén en La hora pico de
esta mañana una mató a un joven de 16
años ninguna organización a reivindicado
el ataque pero tanto jamás como la yihat
islámica lo consideran una respuesta
lógica a la mortífera ocupación israelí
de hecho este año ha sido el más
mortífero para la población Palestina en
cisjordania ocupada allí precisamente
hoy un joven palestino murió tras
recibir un disparo durante una redada
del ejército de Israel en
y el presidente de Turquía recepta Jeep
erdogan recibió en ankara al mandatario
cubano Miguel Díaz canel quien realiza
una gira internacional que ya lo llevó a
Argelia y a Rusia y que seguirá en China
en el encuentro en la capital turca los
mandatarios firmaron acuerdos
bilaterales entre otras áreas en el
sector energético dado que la isla sufre
cortes eléctricos constantes debido en
parte al embargo que la impone a Estados
Unidos y que anualmente la comunidad
internacional condena con amplísimas
mayoría en la asamblea general de
Naciones Unidas
y el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición de Venezuela reiniciarán los
diálogos los próximos días 25 y 26 de
noviembre es decir este viernes hay este
sábado así lo anunció en un mensaje de
Twitter el presidente colombiano Gustavo
Petro recordemos que tras su llegada al
poder Petro restableció las relaciones
diplomáticas entre Bogotá y Caracas y
que junto con el presidente de Argentina
Alberto Fernández y el francés Emmanuel
macron participaron en un encuentro este
noviembre en París donde el oficialismo
y la oposición de Venezuela se
encontraron por primera vez desde los
diálogos de México del año pasado
Y ante la multiplicación de los muros
físicos y administrativos del Norte
global para muchas personas la única
manera de emigrar es a través de rutas
clandestinas sin embargo los caminos
migratorios irregulares son
evidentemente mucho más peligrosos para
la vida de las personas que los viajes
regulares según un nuevo informe de la
organización internacional de las
migraciones desde 2014 50.000 personas
han muerto mientras se desplazaban de un
país a otro previamente hablamos con
Edwin viales de la hoym sobre la
influencia de la industria de la defensa
y de la seguridad en la orientación de
las políticas migratorias
esto sin duda es esto un tema verdad el
todo el tema de la securitización de las
migraciones o de un enfoque punitivo o
de un enfoque policial hacia el abordaje
de las migraciones sin duda que es un
aliciente puede provocar fallecimientos
y desapariciones durante el tránsito
migratorio cuando se habla de temas
migratorios en general no solo de
personas migrantes fallecidas y
desaparecidas sin duda tanto los los
gobiernos y los diferentes entes
encargados de administrar las
migraciones en el mundo deben tener
presente que esté abortarse desde un
enfoque humanista verdad priorizando
siempre a las personas migrantes y sus
familias como centro de todos los
esfuerzos que se hagan y comprendiendo
también que la migración en muchos
sentidos entraña una oportunidad de
desarrollo para todas las naciones donde
llegan las personas migrantes que
atraviesen estas peligrosas rutas
Y ante la violencia de las políticas
migratorias la solidaridad humana en la
frontera entre México y Estados Unidos
familias mexicanas acogen en sus casas a
personas migrantes que esperan su
oportunidad para entrar en territorio
estadounidense en la localidad
fronteriza de Matamoros los refugios y
los albergues están llenos por lo que
menores y adultos se quedarían a la
intemperie si no fuera por la
solidaridad de los habitantes locales en
esta época del año las temperaturas
están cerca de los 7 grados Celsius pero
la lluvia y el viento provocan que la
sensación térmica sea todavía menor
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24 y Frank
24.com
[Música]